casting directors don't always get it
right from Heroes of Middle Earth or the
most evil men in the Galaxy these actors
weren't the first choice for their roles
but they were the best ones
released in 2008 Iron Man was the film
that launched the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it introduced the iconic
character of Tony Stark to millions of
people a role that cemented Robert
Downey Jr as one of the most well-known
and highest paid actors in the MCU to
date in the first film Tony's best
friend James Roadie Rhodes is portrayed
by Terence Howard who was a real-life
friend of Downey Jr at the time
initially Howard seemed like a perfect
fit for Marvel as he just come off his
oscar-nominated role in Hustle and Flow
and his part in the academy
award-winning film crash however after
the massive success of Iron Man Howard
allegedly wanted a pay increase to match
that of lead Downey Jr in an appearance
on Bravo's Watch What Happens Live
Howard revealed that he had a three-film
contract with Marvel and that they were
supposed to pay him eight million
dollars for the sequel however after all
was said and done he was only offered
one million dollars with the rest of his
salary going to Downey Jr according to
Howard Downey Jr wouldn't have landed
the role of Iron Man it wasn't for him
because of the drama Howard was given
the boot and replaced by fellow crash
star Don Cheadle Cheadle would go on to
portray the character of roadie turned
War Machine in multiple other films
including an upcoming lead role in Phase
5's armor Wars while Howard's
performance was good in Iron Man Cheeto
brings a certain Elegance to the role as
he grows into more than just Iron Man's
sidekick throughout the franchise hey
buddy
to expect to see you here look it's me
I'm here to deal with it let's move on I
just I drop it
while Iron Man may have been the film to
launch the MCU it was 2000's X-Men that
helped to catapult the superhero genre
back into the pop culture Stratosphere
the success of X-Men in 2000 can't be
overstated it launched a franchise of 10
X-Men films along with two Deadpool
movies so far and a spin-off in the New
Mutants anchoring the entire franchise
is the longtime presence of Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine a character so
popular that he essentially became the
main protagonist of most of the films
however when X-Men was first being
developed casting directors initially
offered the part to Russell Crowe who
turned it down the role then went to De
Grace Scott but due to scheduling
conflicts with Mission Impossible 2 he
had to back out of the role after that
the director turned to the then unknown
Australian actor Hugh Jackman axeman is
all the better for it Jackman has
consistently put his all into the part
culminating in a truly remarkable
performance in 2017's Logan Jackman's
portrayal has so loved that it's almost
impossible to think of anyone else
playing Wolverine now that the X-Men are
coming to the MCU and it's only a matter
of time before Jackman reprises the role
in Deadpool 3. because I'm the best
there is what I do what I do best isn't
very nice
reshoots are very expensive by Nature so
the prospect of replacing an entire role
especially a central one after a film is
nearing completion is almost unheard of
however following the shocking
allegations of sexual assault that we're
levied against Kevin Spacey in 2017
director Ridley Scott made the decision
to cut Spacey completely from his role
in the film all the money in the world
the actor had already filmed most of his
scenes for the film but Scott hired
celebrated star Christopher Plummer to
step in and portray the role of Jay Paul
Getty instead plumber began working on
reshoots of the Getty Oil Company
founder right away as Ridley was
determined to still meet the movie's
original release date Not only was this
a morally Sound Decision on Scott's part
but it was also a boon for the film
Plummer was nominated for best
supporting actor at the 2018 Academy
Awards for his work on the roll
Michelle Pfeiffer's alluring performance
says Catwoman and Tim Burton's Batman
Returns Almost Never Happened initially
the role was given to oscar-nominated
actress Annette Benning who had to
suddenly drop onto the film after
discovering she was pregnant with her
first child with her husband Warren
Beatty according to Insider the
producers of the film were in a panic
trying to find a replacement for the
role at the last minute Benning had
already been fitted for Catwoman's
skin-tight outfit so the casting team
was looking for people who could both
act the part and fit in the costume
luckily Michelle Pfeiffer was not only
the perfect size for the costuming but
her performance in the role was a truly
defining one for the character it's no
wonder that she's consistently ranked as
one of the best actresses to have ever
played the role of the whip slinging
anti-hero I am Catwoman
hear me roar
Believe It or Not 1984's Beverly Hills
Cop was supposed to Star not Eddie
Murphy but Sylvester Stallone the film
was originally meant to be an
action-packed Thriller Stallone had a
more brutal story planned for the film
even suggesting that the character name
be changed from Axel Foley to Axel
cabretti while this obviously never came
to be the name cabretti would later go
to Stallone's character in 1986's Cobra
meanwhile the studio decided to go in an
entirely different direction as
Stallone's new suggestions would have
bumped the cost of Production Way up
just like that stone was out and Eddie
Murphy was in Murphy's Beverly Hills Cop
struck a lighter tone resulting in one
of the most successful comedy franchises
ever two sequels released in 1987 and
1994 and a much hyped fourth installment
is on the way
nowadays it's pretty much impossible to
think of his steel door's air and the
true king of Gondor as being anyone
other than Viggo Mortensen however many
people have been surprised to learn that
he only took on the role of Aragorn once
shooting was already underway for the
Lord of the Rings The Fellowship of the
Ring initially Peter Jackson's epic
Trilogy had Stuart Townsend cast in the
role but after filming just four short
days Jackson reportedly decided that the
actor was simply too young Townsend
later revealed that he was almost
relieved when he was fired as his
experience with the studio and director
was not a positive one however he was
still quite miffed that after months of
training and rehearsing for the role he
never got paid for his time due to the
terms of his contract nevertheless once
Hugo Mortensen was brought on to replace
him the cast was able to work together
to create the cultural phenomenon that
was The Lord of the Rings thanks to
mortensen's portrayal Aragorn has become
one of the most popular characters from
the Blockbuster franchise I would have
gone with you to the end
before his appearance in The Avengers in
2012 the character of Bruce Banner more
commonly known as the Hulk was initially
portrayed by two other actors in major
Silver Screen Productions first Eric
Bana took on the role in Ang Lee's 2003
film Hulk and this time Edward Norton
portrayed the titular character Norton
was originally meant to keep the role
when the Hulk was brought into the
larger story in The Avengers but there
were some severe and dramatic
behind-the-scenes complications that led
to his recasting the studio ended up
hiring Mark Ruffalo who would go on to
play the character in every subsequent
MCU film featuring The Character thus
far compared to the other iterations
ruffalo's Hulk is quieter in his
demeanor the actor brings out more of
his loneliness intellect collaborative
spirit and kindness all traits that were
missing in the other portrayals of the
character it's because of this that
ruffalo's Bruce Banner has truly grown
into his own I put the brains and the
bra and they get it and now they give me
Best of Both Worlds
Back to the Future is another franchise
that has been famously plagued with
various casting Replacements fans of the
franchise know that Marty's girlfriend
Jennifer Parker was portrayed by Claudia
wells in the first film but when it came
time to shoot Back to the Future Part 2
she was replaced by Elizabeth's shoe
there's also the very messy matter of
Jeffrey Weissman replacing Crispin
Glover as George McFly after a pay
dispute with the studio Glover was
replaced by Wiseman who wore Prosthetics
to look like Glover in the sequel film
Glover then sued over the use of His
Image without his consent and thanks in
part to his suit Studios have largely
avoided using actors likenesses without
permission ever since however the most
notable replacement and the only one
that we'd consider a great upgrade for
the film was when production decided to
have Michael J fox replace Eric Stoltz
as Marty Back to the Future was already
four weeks into production with Stoltz
playing the film's lead character when
director Roberts meccus decided he just
wasn't right for the role zemeckis felt
that Stoltz was too serious instead said
wanting the project to be more light and
carefree Fox whose schedule was
complicated by his commitment to the hit
series Family Ties eventually came in to
reshoot Marty's already completed scenes
and finished the film The actor brought
all of the desired energy to the
character transforming the film into a
full-on franchise and one of the most
iconic and influential Sci-Fi movies in
cinematic history
the 2005 dystopian political drama V for
Vendetta initially starred actor James
Purifoy in the role of V an eccentric
masked vigilante who attempts to spark
Revolution through acts of terrorism
pure voice spent six weeks filming the
role of Eve before ultimately leaving
the movie there were rumors flying
around that he couldn't stand wearing
the mask that actually wasn't the case
Purefoy stated that both he and
production agreed not to go into details
over why he left the project but he
assured fans that it wasn't over him
having to wear a mask for the role once
Purefoy left the film Hugo weaving
stepped in to replace him while Purefoy
may very well have done an excellent job
if he'd stuck with the role weaving's
performance is downright perfect the
actor is able to embody the strength and
emotion of the character without using
any facial expressions there's a reason
V's mask has become such an immortal
image after all I'm not questioning your
powers of observation I'm merely
remarking upon the Paradox of asking a
masked man who he is
While most actor placements made way
into production require massive reshoots
the one in Spike Jones's sci-fi romance
her required only minimal revision
initially it was Samantha Morton who was
cast to play Samantha The Faceless
artificial intelligence that Joaquin
Phoenix's character finds himself
falling in love with Morton recorded all
of her lines and Phoenix's acting was
timed with her vocal rhythms but it
wasn't until after the movie wrapped
that director Jones decided Morton
wasn't right for the role Jones told
vulture that it was during the editing
stage in post-production that he
realized Morton's delivery didn't create
the effect that he wanted that was when
he chose to recast the role with
Scarlett Johansson revised the character
and bring Phoenix back to redo some of
his own lines as well ultimately this
was the right call as johansen's
performance was highly celebrated
including a win for best actress at the
Rome film festival in 2013. Johansen
would later use her voice acting talents
again in films like The Jungle Book Isle
of dogs and sing too thanks in part to
Johann his involvement her is able to
present a complex and compelling
relationship between Phoenix's character
and his beloved AI
when Star Wars A New Hope was released
in 1977 Darth Vader was the villain of
everyone's worst nightmares so when it
came time to reveal that there was an
even bigger Baddie pulling Vader's
strings in the follow-up films that
casting had to be on point whoever
played the evil emperor had to be more
menacing than Vader a seemingly
impossible task in Star Wars The Empire
Strikes Back the emperor is voiced by
Clive Revel and portrayed by actress
Marjorie Eaton however when it came time
to really develop the character and have
Luke Skywalker face off with him in
Return of the Jedi Ian McDermott was
cast to play both his voice and body
McDermott would continue to reprise his
character in the prequel and sequel
films although it ended up being a
subtle change it made all the difference
the intensity and power that McDermott
brings to the role is unmatched
audiences can instantly detect that
there's something sinister about
Palpatine but we can also see how he's
so easily deceived everyone around him
without McDermott portrayal of the
emperor Star Wars would not be what it
is today in time you will call me master
director James Cameron's alien sequel
introduced audiences to the likable
Corporal Hicks a Space Marine and
potential love interest for Sigourney
Weaver's leading hero Ripley initially
Cameron cast James Remar in the role of
hicks but he was later fired and
replaced by Michael Bean according to
screenrant Remar was reportedly
incredibly difficult to work with on set
and as such his portrayal of hicks was a
lot darker than was originally intended
Remar later admitted that he was
suffering from a serious drug addiction
during the time of filming and that
likely resulted in his being let go and
replaced in the project Bean was brought
in as the replacement fresh off his
success from Terminator he brought a
different perspective to the character
of Corporal Hicks one that aligned more
with Cameron's original Vision however
if you look closely at aliens there are
still a few moments where you can see
remar's Hicks as it was too expensive to
reshoot and replace every single one of
his scenes with Bean
thank you